oh
sorry
huh
what are they from
here i'll come up but no
there's no way in here
hello hello my check my check my check
my check
so
oh i'm sorry i was just going to call
this a good action right
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry about that
i'm sorry about that
so
all right then i just sent you the uh
livestream
and then uh just a two minute warning to
some of the other stations and
yeah but the interpreter is not here yet
we can't start
and i'm like what is going on
um
hey so the interpreter is not here yet
so don't let them come down here
okay okay
okay all right i just wanted to make
sure you were handling that so we didn't
have to worry about it
okay i'll holler in a second okay bye
thank god i just didn't want them coming
look we're up on the satellite right now
so just be careful what you say because
everybody here thank you
everybody
let's go
um
so
is
foreign
like that
okay
i'll do it
so
is
they're coming down the elevator now
he said this is good
will be live in one minute
40 seconds yeah
30 seconds
10 9 eight
seven six five
okay well uh good afternoon
and uh thank you for joining us for this
important update on our efforts to
keep michigan safe law enforcement is
always a team effort and today i am
grateful
to stand alongside four leading partners
who worked collaboratively
and decisively to thwart a serious
incredible
threat to public safety this effort
would not have been possible
without a unified front including all
levels of law enforcement focused on
protecting the safety
and well-being of our citizens so today
i am joined by a u.s attorney for the
western district of michigan andrew
burch
u.s attorney for the eastern district of
michigan matthew schneider
any moment now we will have
the fbi assistant special agent in
charge
josh hoaxhurst and we have
michigan state police colonel joe gasper
the interagency effort represented here
in tandem with my office
culminated in the execution of several
search warrants and arrests
across the state including in the
communities of grand rapids
heartland luther canton
orion township waterford
belleville milford
shelbyville plainwell zealand
munich ovid kalamazoo
charlotte clarkston sterling heights
and shelby township our efforts
uncovered elaborate plans to endanger
the lives
of law enforcement officers government
officials
and the broader public the multi-front
operation to apprehend the suspects in
question was carefully coordinated
and skillfully executed resulting very
fortunately in no casualties
now before we announce the preliminary
charges i want to thank the
hundreds of law enforcement officers who
worked
across agencies and across state lines
and we are
very grateful for their safety and with
that
i'll ask u.s attorney for the western
district of michigan
mr andrew burge to tell you a little bit
more about the effort
good afternoon thank you attorney
general nessal
last night the fbi and michigan state
police
arrested six individuals charged in a
federal complaint
with conspiring to kidnap the governor
of michigan
gretchen whitmer according to the
complaint
unsealed this morning adam fox
barry croft ty garvin
caleb franks daniel harris
and brandon caserta conspired to kidnap
the governor from her vacation home
in the western district of michigan
before the november election
under federal law each of these
individuals faces
a term of any number of years up to life
in prison
if convicted fox garben franks
harris and caserta are residents of
michigan
croft is a resident of delaware
all of us standing here today want the
public to know
that federal and state law enforcement
are committed to working together
to make sure violent extremists never
succeed
with their plans particularly
when they target our duly elected
leaders
the federal complaint in this case
alleges that the fbi
began an investigation earlier this year
after becoming aware
that through social media that a group
of individuals was discussing
the violent overthrow of certain
government and law enforcement
components
through confidential sources undercover
agents
and clandestine recordings law
enforcement learned
particular individuals were planning to
kidnap
the governor and acting in furtherance
of that plan
the alleged conspirators used
operational security measures
including communicating by encrypted
messaging platforms
and used code words and phrases in an
attempt to avoid detection by law
enforcement among other activities
members of this conspiracy on two
occasions conducted coordinated
coordinated surveillance on the
governor's vacation home
fox and croft in particular according to
the complaint discussed
detonating explosive devices to divert
police
from the area of the home and fox even
inspected
the underside of a michigan highway
bridge for places to seat an explosive
the complaint further alleges that fox
purchased a taser for use
in the kidnapping and that the group
successfully detonated
an improvised explosive device wrapped
with shrapnel
to test its anti-personnel capabilities
the fbi and state police execute arrests
of several of the conspirators
when they were meeting on the east side
of the state to pool funds
for explosives and exchange tactical
gear
this investigation is ongoing agents of
the detroit field office of the fbi
and other members of their joint
terrorism task force
including the not
is prosecuting available federal case
u.s attorney's offices in the eastern
district of michigan
and delaware are and have been assisting
and the state of michigan has brought
related charges
against other individuals
of course those charged with a crime
still have rights
that we respect the allegations in a
complaint are
accusations a defendant is presumed
innocent until unless proven guilty in a
court of law
these defendants have begun to make
their initial appearances in federal
court
and the court will be scheduling their
arraignments
as well as bond and preliminary hearings
now it is my privilege to introduce to
you the us attorney
for the eastern district of michigan
matthew schneider for some additional
remarks
thank you
thank you andrew
good afternoon all of us in michigan
can disagree about politics but those
disagreements
should never ever amount to violence
because of the hard work of the men and
women of law enforcement police officers
and federal agents violence has been
prevented today
this case is being brought in the
western district of michigan some of the
defendants reside in the eastern
district where some of the search
warrants took place
but at the end of the day what matters
most is that the people of michigan
should be reassured that our state and
federal governments
are working together to keep us all safe
i wanted to to thank attorney general
nessel and her office
for her outstanding work and her
committed
partnership i also thank colonel gaspar
the fbi and of course u.s attorney burge
every day police officers and federal
agents put their lives on the line
and they do that for us in this case the
agents made
swift and safe arrests and those were
done by those officers and agents
we are most thankful to them thank you
it's my pleasure now to introduce the
director of the michigan state police
colonel joe gasper
thank you attorney general nessal u.s
attorneys
burge and schneider and thank you to the
fbi also
i appreciate the opportunity to speak to
everyone today and i'd first like to
start out by
saying thank you to the men and women of
the michigan state police
the the fbi and any additional
agencies that assisted in this
investigation
they not only worked tirelessly over the
course of the last 24 to 48 hours
but also since the beginning of this
investigation
so thank you job well done
to the partners here today you know i
want to express
our gratitude for the support and the
cooperation
um the partnership that all of us here
are demonstrating
this case is one of the largest cases in
recent history that the msp has been
involved in
and i think that the nature of this case
is rather unprecedented
but it does send a very vivid reminder
that while we may be in a time period
of discourse possibly even divisiveness
and fighting across the nation law
enforcement
stands united and for those who think
that law enforcement is distracted
let me assure you that we are very much
engaged
with taking our responsibility to
protect the public
very seriously we take
we took an oath to protect and defend
and to serve and together we will take
swift action
against anyone who is planning or
seeking to commit violence
or harm to anyone in the state of
michigan
thank you again for the cooperation and
i will now turn it back to
attorney general
okay well unfortunately it appears as
though
uh fbi uh assistant special agent uh
uh hawks hurst uh has not uh made it
with us in time but um
is he here he's on his way okay well if
he gets here when i'm done speaking
um i will try to speak slowly so that um
we can make time for his appearance but
uh anyway thanks again to uh to the
colonel
and to of course u.s attorneys burj and
schneider
uh and uh you know the fbi
state police uh everyone's effort here
so important but i'd like to announce
that my office
has filed uh additional charges in
addition to the charges
already announced by the u.s attorney's
office in the western district
an account of the state we have
additional
charges so i'd like to announce the
following preliminary charges pursuant
to the michigan
anti-terrorism act against seven
individuals all of whom are now
in custody linked to the militia group
wolverine watchmen
and associates of wolverine watchmen
the individuals in custody are suspected
to have attempted to identify the home
addresses of law enforcement officers
in order to target them made threats of
violence
intended to instigate a civil war and
engaged in planning
and training for an operation to attack
the capitol building
of michigan and to kidnap government
officials
including the governor of michigan now
it's important to note
that these charges are subject to change
after a complete review of the evidence
obtained last night
and may differ from those charged at the
federal level
so we've issued the following charges
against the following individuals
paul beller age 21 of milford
who is charged with three felony counts
uh providing material support for
terrorist
acts a 20-year felony and or 20 000
fine gang membership a 20-year felony
which may be served as a consecutive
sentence carrying or possessing
a firearm during the commission of a
felony otherwise known as felony firearm
a two-year mandatory prison sentence to
be served
consecutive to the other charges
sean fix age 38 of belleville charged
with two felony counts
providing material support for terrorist
acts a 20-year felony
carrying or possessing a firearm during
the commission of a felony
felony firearm eric molitor
age 36 of cadillac charged with two
felony counts providing material support
for terrorist acts
and carrying or possessing a firearm
during the commission
of a felony felony firearm michael null
age 38 of plainwell charged with two
felony counts providing material support
for terrorist acts
and carrying or possessing a firearm
during the commission of a felony
felony firearm william null
a shelbyville charged with two felony
counts
providing material support for terrorist
acts and carrying or possessing
a firearm during the commission of a
felony felony firearm
and finally pete musico age 42
and joseph morrison age 42
who live together in munich and these
men are both charged
with four felony counts one count
uh of threat of terrorism a twenty year
felony
and or twenty thousand dollar fine one
count of gang membership
again a twenty year felony that may be
served as a consecutive sentence
one count each of providing material
support for terrorist
acts and one count each for carrying
or possessing a firearm during the
commission of a felony felony firearm
and before i continue with my remarks
i see that fbi assistant special agent
in charge
josh hoxhurst is here and
like to bring him up for a few remarks
good morning thank you on behalf of the
fbi
in michigan i would like to thank you
and our partners of the u.s attorney's
offices of both the western and eastern
districts of michigan and the michigan
attorney general's office and the
michigan state police
the primary mission of the fbi is to
protect the american people
and uphold the constitution this
investigation is
is an example of our continued
commitment to that mission
to both protect the people of this state
and to adhere to the rights reserved by
the constitution
the alleged conspirators are extremists
who undertook a plot to kidnap
a sitting governor whenever extremists
move into the realm
of actually plotting or planning violent
acts
the fbi's joint terrorism task force
stands ready to identify
disrupt and dismantle their operations
preventing them
from following through on those plans
an operation of this scope cannot occur
without the assistance
of law enforcement agencies large and
small we are incredibly
proud of the work of our agents task
force officers
and law enforcement partners during last
night's operation
and throughout the course of this
investigation
we rely on the public's assistance to
help keep us
safe if you see suspected criminal
activity
and want to report to the fbi please
call 1-800
call fbi or submit tips online
at tips.fbi.gov thank you
you special agent well with that um
i just uh want to do a few things first
of all
um i think it's important uh to give a
shout out at least to
my staff uh since i have the ability to
do that since um
we're in our home offices here and i
just want to uh
with deep gratitude uh thank uh
solicitor general fadwa hamoud
chief deputy christina grassi chief of
our criminal division
danielle hackman-clark john palace our
first assistant
in our criminal division the head of our
hate crimes division
sunita darumani and tom fabus
who is the chief of our investigative
unit so i wanted to say
thanks to all of you uh and in addition
of course it's always important again to
reiterate
that a criminal charge is merely an
allegation and the defendants are
presumed innocent
unless and until proven guilty um but
with that i
i want to thank everyone up here in law
enforcement
and everyone who participated in this
matter and who will continue of course
to participate in this matter
uh for their incredible efforts uh their
very brave efforts
over the course of the past many months
and to say to them that your efforts
have left
the people of this state safer and the
instruments of our government
stronger and i know that i speak on
behalf of michiganders
all across this state when i say that we
are grateful and we are indebted
to you for your actions so thank you
very much
you